you got it right i've got it wrong so
wrong you have to look
at the effect on the banking industry as
well as
the auto industry my friend when you do
the bottom line the only conclusion
is that obama is a disaster
are you a republican
now first let me just say that i'm
encouraged that so many of you from the
republican party
have agreed to meet me in this way
now as you know i've tried very hard to
reach across the aisle
and govern this country from the middle
well
all due respect mr president
we disagree with you we think you should
run the country from
not the middle well that's why we're
here
if you would i'd just appreciate some
feedback on some new ideas and
directions for this country
feel free to agree or disagree
whatever you want we're gonna disagree
disagree disagree
disagree first
i think the government is too big i
think we need to shrink the size of the
federal government
so that all decisions can be made at the
state level
we disagree mr president
you drive a hard bargain you win
there we go big
government it is
next up this has been a hot button issue
but i think we can settle it right here
no taxes for rich people we completely
disagree
round two goes to you guys
okay more taxes for the rich
what the what is happening to us
and i am taking a beating here guys all
right
last issue immigration now
we need to secure our borders and
anybody who's here illegally should be
hunted down
and deported
[Music]
if we disagree
we are a country of immigrants no
we need a clear path to citizenship for
all of those who are already here
help me
[Music]
great i love your ideas lastly we cannot
regulate
firearms
all right all right you guys say so
and nobody better throw me a cigarette
ain't i a stinker
[Music]
wasn't that the turn for our polling
station uh why no young man
uh see we we know a uh shorter route
to your uh to our democratic polling
station you know how us democrats like a
shortcut
like government spending to prop up the
economy nothing more we love than those
uh federal programs you two
are democrats aren't you what
of course we are you see the color of
our skin don't you how could we not
blindly vote democratic i mean that
would be ridiculous whatever
all i know is my polling place closed in
15 minutes why that would be terrible
awful i mean how are you going to elect
tax and spend politicians if you can't
vote
it's hard enough to vote with all those
voter id laws
republicans
this is gosh darn republicans i know i'm
just like girl
douglas right you know if there were any
republicans here
oh i'd be pissed i'd be royally pissed
in fact i would take their hard-fought
principles and not shh
right off their keisters we seem to be
driving in circles
uh don't worry we're almost there
look it appears we've hit somebody we
should get out and help him
oh oh oh my leg oh my gosh
i am pissed i'm royally pissed
now although it was only this one man's
fault i will be using all of the old
tax dollars to get healthy thanks to the
uh affordable health care act
i know it doesn't seem fair but that's
supposedly the law of the land out here
that's what i've heard you don't look
that hurt why you're wearing those same
leather jackets
and those dad jeans disperse
black republican mother
[Music]
[Applause]
this november you got to get out and
vote it's all about democracy y'all
your vote gets counted with the rest of
the votes in the country and they get
sent off to the electoral college
what's that the electoral college are a
bunch of officials who do the voting for
us so in case we elect the wrong person
they can fix their shares hold up
who the hell are these people well no
one knows for sure but whoever they is
they the folks who actually do the real
voting after we do
our pretend vote yeah power to the
people hold the
guard you're telling me our votes don't
matter
our votes are like suggestions so this
november we should
yeah dunk the vote
these allegations that i have sent
inappropriate pictures
over the internet are completely
ridiculous they are levied
by my political rivals who are trying to
embarrass me
and advance their own agenda so let me
be
perfectly clear these allegations are
false
and i will be vindicated
tmz has obtained an actual photo of your
genitalia they're posting it to their
website as we speak
they're saying you took it how do you
respond
okay i may have sent one photo of my
genitalia
all right okay that's an isolated
incident it was a one-time thing
senator what about the new report that
there are three new pictures having been
sent to three different women
what second rate news organization is
trying to new york times
okay it was it was four total no more
that was it it was just one
there was four and no more yes amy yes
you are sure that there were only four
photos sent that's it four
that's all there's no more than four
then how do you explain the one you sent
me
please please i'm begging you i'm
begging you
to forgive me for the the foibles
and transgressions it was the reckless
act of a younger man
a younger man you sent it two seconds
before you stepped on stage
senator senator that's very decent amy
last time i checked
time is still real okay so technically
speaking
i am much older now than i was all of
those seconds ago
are you guys oh my god yeah what's
happening right now i just got one
what's going on i don't understand
what's happening oh that's nasty senator
how are you even doing this
you have no proof that i'm doing
anything oh my god
i'm sorry again i'm sorry one more time
oh wait a second you can do it but i
can't do it
treatment
folks i have a simple philosophy that
government should work for everyone not
just the elite
and that's why i helped pass the farm
bill because i care about farmers
but i won't stop there i will work
for everyone whether you are
young whether you are old whether you
are asian or hispanic whether you
are straight or whether you are gay
i will work for all of you
and that's why i also support marriage
equality
folks don't choose to be gay any more
than i
choose to be straight could you imagine
if someone told you that you couldn't
marry
the person that you loved
i'm sorry i think gays are people too
gays are not different gays
they are just like us they love
they fear they raise their children
they strive for a better life but there
are those
who believe that being gay is an
abomination
that's absurd the homosexual community
is a valuable community in this country
they are doctors they are lawyers
they are teachers they are me
and they are you and their contributions
are no less important than any other
group
in this fine nation of ours
so turn to that gay person
near you and see
that they are no different than you are
thank you it's okay
no no here's the thing here's the thing
okay i guarantee you i guarantee you if
you look at obamacare
25 years from now and you look at the
number of enrollees
no no no no you guys got it wrong you
have to look at the amount of people
enrolled in the health care system and
the tremendous effect
that it has on the economy you're
missing the point you are missing the
point what you have to do
what you have to do is look at the
tremendous effect that obamacare is
having
on the u.s economy and in addition you
have to look at the government bailouts
of the auto industry in the banking
industry
you got it right i've got it wrong so
wrong you have to look
at the effect on the banking industry as
well as
the auto industry my friend when you do
the bottom line the only conclusion
is that obama is a disaster
are you a republican
yes i'd like to apologize
for this programming mistake in the
future we will do better
at choosing our guests here on
diametrically opposed